hi everybody thank you for joining us
today
my name is Hideo Kojima and I'm the
product manager on the Android
application team here at Google and we
are here today to talk about best
practices for getting your users signed
into your Android app so let's dive
straight in now as I'm sure you're all
aware user authentication can be a
complex problem there are lots of
different solutions out there and it can
get very confusing very quickly
especially from the users perspective
now let's imagine your user or a user
goes and downloads an app and is taken
to this sign-in page now at the top of
the page
they might see buttons to sign-in using
a federated identity provider and at
this point the user might be wondering
hmm what are these buttons have I used
them before
can I trust them and as the user makes
their way further down the page now they
might see the classic username and
password entry fields and at this point
if the user is anything like me they're
probably realising that they completely
forgot their credentials ultimately if
this were your app your user might go
through a password or account recovery
flow which could be costly for you guys
or they might end up signing up creating
and signing up with a brand new account
which could lead to a loss of user data
and ultimately or possibly less user
engagements worse yet you might end up
losing that user entirely so as you
think through the sign-in problem
you're probably wondering which are the
different options you should be offering
to your users as I mentioned in the
previous slide you can allow your users
to sign in using a federated identity
provider such as Google you can also
offer the classic username and password
option you can also allow users to sign
up using their phone number or sign in
using biometrics and it's not just
sign-in that you're worried about right
once your users are sign
then you want to make sure that both
your users and your app are protected
from account abuse you also want to make
sure your users can easily and securely
submit their payment information so with
all of the different things that you
have to consider you might be asking
yourself so where do I start what are
all of the things that I should be
considering as I design and develop my
app so our objective for today is to
provide guidance on the following
questions number one how do I simplify
the onboarding process for my users
number two once my users are signed in
how do i facilitate payment transactions
and number three how do I prevent
account abuse and as we walk through
these questions today we want to make
sure that we keep the end customer user
journey in mind because as I'm sure we
all agree that's what's most important
and we want to make sure that we put we
do our best to put two guys in a
position to be successful so now I'm
gonna hand it off to Carlos is going to
talk about the onboarding process thanks
Eddie rocky my name is Carlos and I lead
the account attend ocation management
and security efforts within Android and
I'm here today to talk to you about both
getting your users into your app and
that's it having them authenticate well
as well as to sort of keep them in your
app specifically I'm gonna talk to you
about Google sign-in Google smart lock
for passwords as well as autofill with
Google I should note that I'm not going
to be like work through any sort of code
examples here but at the end of the
presentation we'll have a slide with a
bunch of links that are sort of links to
the relevant developer documentation
Google sign-in provides the simplest
onboarding as well as rewarding
experience for your users it is one tap
to get you users onboard and subsequent
like sign ins from the user either on
the web or on Android or on iOS devices
it's completely automatic and it also
provides the best security story for
your users as Google sort of provides
more services to users to be able to
prevent phishing etc you'll benefit from
that if you have if you have you
there's our google signed in the doodle
app which does you know meetings and
sort of meeting organization it saw a
substantial improvement when they sort
of meant over to the Google sign-in for
their initial registrations if you're
unable to sort of do client-side and
server-side integrations then Google
smartlock may be your best bet it's only
a client-side integration and what it
allows you to do is programmatically
integrate with a store of usernames and
passwords that are managed by Google
those passwords are also used for Chrome
password management as well as for
autofill and with this you can sort of
have your users go through a traditional
signup flow but when they subsequently
resign in it can just be completely
automatic
you just programmatically get the
password you don't need to show a
username or password prompt and it's a
fantastic user experience Netflix as a
result of this has seen a substantial
reduction and sort of like contacts with
their users when they're asking for help
because they forgot their usernames and
passwords finally if you're unable to do
any substantial integration on the
client-side autofill with Google is our
attempt to help your users get into your
apps it's available and sort of Oreo
plus devices for about 45% of those
users are opted in and we're filling
millions of passwords every day and how
it works again is that your app is in
front of the user it's showing a
username and password field we do our
best integrating with the framework to
be able to detect that field and make a
suggestion to the user about what the
right sign-in is in all of these cases
there are things that you can do to help
us help you specifically if you're going
to use Google sign-in or you going to
use smart lock for passwords you can
register your app with the Google
developer console this will help Google
tell you tell us like what your app is
it helps with quota and it's just a
necessary feature of using those api's
in addition we I want to sort of suggest
that you also sort of set up digital
asset links with your apps if you have a
presence in the web and a presence and
an Android app it really helps us reuse
passwords between the two for both smart
lock for passwords and for autofill with
Google and how you do that is you just
have your domain serve an asset link
file
and then you sort of make a declaration
in your Android manifest again there
will be a link at the end of the
presentation
so to summarize Google sign-in one tap
to get your users on and then it's just
automatic afterwards well programmatic
for you but automatic for your users and
it works on all Android operating
systems it works on iOS it works on the
web smart lock for passwords there will
be a manual onboarding process but once
you sort of programmatically integrate
with it it means that subsequent
signings by the your users will work on
all Android devices and it's again
automaticall finally autofill with
Google will allow you to have your users
get back into your app with suggested
usernames and passwords from from Google
and that will make it much easier to get
your users back on board with identities
that you are already aware of and it's
available on Oreo Plus Android phones
finally if you're going to you using
sort of phone number verification for
example it's very common for for apps to
use OTPs to to get their to verify their
users identity there will be policy
changes coming in the future
traditionally apps have taken the SMS
permission or the call logs permission
but the Play Store is changing their
policies regarding this and those in
apps that take those permissions are
going to get a lot more scrutiny so we
suggest that you take a look at the
Google Play services SMS retriever API
it allows you to sort of
programmatically integrate with the
Google Play services and what will
happen is that you'll still send an SMS
message to the phone but Google Play
services will mediate that message and
you will only get your OTP the benefit
of this is that you don't need to ask
your users for scary permissions to
still be able to verify their phone
numbers and Flipkart
using this API has found a substantial
increase in sign up to reiterate don't
ask for tons of permissions especially
if they're not directly related to your
business case we live in a climate where
users are very privacy sensitive and
asking for lots of extraneous
permissions that aren't clearly and
obviously related to your business case
is a recipe for problems
so part of the sort of onboarding flow
is also keeping your users on board when
they eventually switch devices and a lot
of what I've talked about already is
relevant to that case where a user sort
of leaves their old device they move to
a new device you know Google sign-in
smart lock for passwords they will just
smoothly have your users sort of
transfer their identity from one form to
the other because it'll just be portable
when you are when you do have an app we
do suggest that you test to make sure
that autofill with Google is correctly
identifying your usernames in your
passwords help us help you in addition
add Recovery Options for when you're
your usernames and passwords it's very
common in an Android app as a ID a key
mention for a user to only enter their
username once and only enter their
password once and then two or three
years later have no idea what that
password is when they start when they
sort of get a new device so if you add
Recovery Options you're going to
increase the chances of keeping your
users finally Google does provide a
backup and restore service to our users
and the benefit of that is that you'd
also back soft and restores app data
including your data so test to make sure
that that that that's working properly
for you and that you can get the most
value out of that and it should make
your that transition from one device to
another as smooth as possible for the
user and ensure that you get the most
value from your user reengagement on a
new phone next Jay is going to talk
about how to facilitate payments Thank
You Carlos hi my name is JC Billy and
I'm a software engineer on the Yoda
field with Google team so Carlos talked
about how we can improve the logging
experience I like to talk about how we
can make the payment experience better
for our users making a payment on a
mobile device can be quite tedious task
you have to get your physical credit
card enter a bunch of numbers on the
soft keyboard it's error-prone it's
tedious and if you're like me chances
are you've been a situation where you've
given up on making a transaction just
because of that the pain because that
process was just too painful so what can
we do the best thing you can do to make
transactions payments easier into your
is integrated with the Google pay api's
they provide a seamless checkout
experience for users and there are the
best way to get your users checked out
so how does that work
you basically provide integrated google
pee-pee is you have a pay button a
Google pay button in your app when the
user press that button they're presented
with the credit card debit card
available on their Google account and
that can easily check out by selecting
one of those account this actually we've
seen for instance Hotel tonight's
conversion rate increase by 65% when
they transition to those Google pay P I
so that really is what we recommend
something to keep in mind that there's
kind of an investment to getting
integrated with these api's you have to
integrate with the entire flow of the
API and with your payment service
providers so if you're not yet ready to
do that work something else you can do
is make sure that autofill works great
with your app something that cars
mention already so order feel is not
just about username and passwords it can
actually help with many other scenarios
like credit cards names first name last
name phone numbers email addresses
physical addresses so anything that's
tedious to enter in an application or a
sale can help so here we are we can see
how it works with payments we're in an
app and somebody the user tapped on the
credit card field and what autofill
provides it shows you that drop down
with a credit card that accessible
that's available the Google account of
the user user can select that drop down
to autofill that credit card into their
form so that's actually used we're
seeing millions of payment millions of
payments form fill with that we sort of
feel every week so that's definitely
something that brings value to the user
something you might be wondering is how
does autofill know when I tap on a
credit card field that this is actually
a credit card field and so the way it
works is that all of your services will
use a bunch of heuristics or other
techniques and then will extract data
from the views to figure out what that
field is but if you want to make sure
they get it right 100% of the autofill
gets it right wondering for some of the
time there's something fairly easy you
can do and
this is using out of your hands so here
we have a code snippet of layout XML
file and worse you can see there's a
text in there and what we've done is
that we've tagged that textview with the
other file hints and we've tagged it
with a credit card number of the fill
hints what does that do it basically
tells you to field service provider that
this field is a credit card so there's
no guessing involved by your field
service and they will show the right
suggestion so you might also be
wondering where does that critical
number constant come from it's actually
a constant found in the Android view
class if you go and take a look in there
you'll see that there's a bunch of those
hints there you see order via lane
prefix
so those autofill hints have been added
in Android oh when the autofill order
field capability was introduced in
Android but we found out that they're
not always as granular as user may want
for instance if you look at name there's
only one in four names there's no
distinction between first name and last
name for that reason we're introducing
soon extended of the field hints so
those new hints will be included in the
compatibility library and it will give
you more control over all different kind
of things you may want to have in your
application so I was talking about names
you see we have now a greater breakdown
of all the different names you could
have in your in your app as well address
and other other types so we saw how you
can actually help other fields so she
has the right thing in your app however
there are cases where you actually don't
want or the field to suggest anything we
can imagine imagine you have an app
where you have an activity to add
friends with their phone numbers so that
activity without only one field which is
phone number when the user taps that
fields taps that field autofill might
detect it as a phone number but in that
case we obviously don't want to suggest
the phone number as a user's phone
number because this is for adding
somebody else so in those cases where
you don't want to autofill to to do any
suggestion you can actually turn out to
turn off autofill by tagging the field
with the important for the field
property so you see in that snippet here
this is a textview
and it's being tagged with important for
the field know what does that do
then instructs Yoda field service please
ignore that that you and Charlie and so
you can use that to disable one field or
more and actually if you have more than
one field let's say in our previous
example in that addfriend activity if
you had multiple field with first name
last name email you want to disable all
of them you can actually set that
important for the field property on a
parent node and you set it with no
exclude descendants and what that does
is that exclude all the nodes located
under that specific node so to recap
what we suggest we do if you want all
the fields we're great in your app it to
grow through your layout XML files and
every time you have an input field
make sure it's either disabled if it
doesn't make sense to have it enable or
specify the right types or the field
works all the time so that's one aspect
of the payment experience we want to be
able to suggest and to make it easy for
users to enter their credit card
information there's another thing that
comes up it's also it's related to our
GPS in some markets like India for
instance every time you make a purchase
online or in an app you have to provide
an OTP provided by your financial
institution so as Carlos talked about we
could use the SMS retriever app we can
use today the SMS rap to retrieve otps
but this is restricted to ATP's you send
yourself in those kind of scenarios
those OTP are sent by a third party so
you don't have control over who's
sending that in the past you would
probably have used the SMS read
permission to actually read the SMS as
they come in and try to find that OTP
yourself but the Carlos mentioned the
play policy the Play Store policy is
changing and we now are trying to help
users not get acts developers not get
access to all the OT all the SMS from
the user for privacy reasons so we're
introducing another API which is the SMS
User Content API was that API does that
we will let you steal access third party
OTPs but they will we will prom the user
so to make sure you know they agree or
providing you that OTP so let's take a
look at how it works here we have Zomato
which is one of our partner app and
they're using the API let's see what
they do so first of all you start the
the
we are these foreign requires an OTP
it's going to call the SMS retriever
start SMS user constant API what that
does is that it is drug Z has a material
constant to start paying attention for
SMS messages coming in with potential
ology peas in them once an OTP comes in
once an SMS message was an OTB comes in
the content API will actually send a
broadcast to your application and that
broadcast will contain constant intent
that you can extract out of the out of
the broadcast and you will have to start
that constant in ten we start activity
for results
what does it do it will show that
dialogue you're seeing there at the
bottom of the screen and this will show
two things to the user first of them you
will tell them which app is requiring
access to the SMS and second it will
actually list the content of the SMS the
user will then be able to see clearly
what it's given to the app once it click
allow then the app in your app you will
on the activity result get the actual
SMS message as part of the data intent
provided on the activity result so you
can then extract the SMS message parse
the OTP and use it in your application
so to recap when it comes to automated
SMS verification you have two options
the first option is using SMS River API
that means you have access to the
backend you you're sending the director
LSMs this is a preferred API to use in
that case because no user consent is
required the experience is pretty
seamless no interaction from the user if
you don't have if you don't have access
to the backend if it's a third party OTP
then you want to use the SMS constant
API so in that case you can use it in
any kind of scenario but user will have
to give permission for every message you
receive that your app needs to consume
and there will be one tap involved in
that case and with that I'm gonna hand
it over to Steven who's going to talk
about how to prevent account views okay
thanks very much Jay so my name is
Steven I'm a product manager here at
Google working on authentication and
secure
so in this last section we're gonna talk
about another problem that comes up for
developers eventually after improving
your onboarding flows and helping users
do things in your apps you'll inevitably
run into the problem of abuse so we're
gonna cover a couple different
categories the first is about the
creation of illegitimate accounts so you
might have encountered this before as
you build an app you'll have people
often through automation trying to
create accounts at scale and there's a
variety of different tools that you are
able to use to help mitigate this
problem so one of the first ones that we
recommend is using a trusted identity
provider for your users so encouraging
people to go through something like a
sign-in with Google flow and the
opportunity the advantage here is that
these identity providers like Google
have done a lot of checks on their users
so in the case of Google accounts when
someone creates a new Google account we
look for all forms of automation try to
detect that and stop these accounts from
being created in the first place so what
you can do as an application developer
is when you see someone come in with a
Google sign-in account you have we will
know that this person has a been through
checks from Google and you're getting
those for free by just having a user use
these flows beyond that of course people
may sign up with other mechanisms and
things like verifying users phone
numbers or forms of payments can be
additional signals that you look at to
try to mitigate abuse from these types
of account creation now the thing to
keep in mind here is that adding checks
on people's phone numbers or forms a
payment introduced additional friction
into the onboarding flows you're trying
to build for users so you have to use
them really carefully and there's the
tools like Carlos mentioned earlier the
SMS retriever that can help you verify
something like a phone number more
easily by automatically reading the
contents of an SMS that contains a
one-time code so keep that in mind when
you're building flows where you have to
verify additional user information and
finally there are api's on Android that
help you detect and prevent the usage of
your app through automated mechanisms
like scripts and BOTS and let's go into
a little bit of detail about those too
so the first one here is the safety net
API and so the safety net API will help
give you an assertion or an attestation
that the user of your app is on a
legitimate real device how this works is
in calling a play services API you can
ask the device to collect a bunch of
information send that to Google and have
Google analyze and determine the
integrity of this device whether it's
real that the OS is intact and so on and
return this assertion back to your app
once you have this information you can
send it to your own server and then use
it as a signal in your own onboarding
flows you have positive reinforcement
that this is in fact a legitimate device
so if you think about it when someone is
trying to create accounts at scale it
really becomes really expensive when
they have to have real devices in order
to create those accounts but sometimes
having a real device isn't enough and
there's another option here which is to
put reCAPTCHA flow into your apps now
again this is one that you want to use
judiciously because people will
potentially run into this when they are
legitimate users and this is going to
add additional friction for those users
so keep in mind that this should only be
used when you really need it when you
have indication that this is a risky
transaction or that there is some form
of abuse that's happened in the past
okay with that you've hopefully created
an account that's legitimate and the
next problem that you'll have to go
through is keeping that account safe so
preventing bad actors from accessing
this account and stealing user data
performing transactions that could be
harmful to the users of your apps so for
this you can use several of the
technologies that we've already
mentioned the first one that we brought
up earlier was using Google sign-in and
a trusted identity provider and this is
a great opportunity because Google does
so many checks when people activate
their Google accounts on an Android
device you've probably encountered this
yourself that we do things like send
notifications on a new sign in event
allow users to go into their account
settings and audit where their account
is active and look at a multitude of
signals about where this event is
happening the history of the device that
you can leverage as a developer by
simply having someone go through a
Google sign-in flow and have those
signals when they're accessing an
account
and your service there's actually an
interesting new feature that came out
recently called cross account protection
where if you've had a user sign into
your Google account with a Google
account into your service you can
subscribe for notifications on security
events related to that account so for
example if this user's account is
hijacked at Google you'll know about
that and can help them secure their
account with your service so a trusted
identity writer is one place to start
with but of course there are people who
are going to sign up without using an
identity provider and for those users
you may want to add additional steps in
the verification flows so that's things
like sending them a one time code via
SMS or some sort of time-based flow to
get additional signals that it's them
and prevent and/or
combat the problem of password reuse or
we o'c weak passwords so there again
this is adding friction potentially for
users so you'll want to use the api's
like SMS retriever to try to mitigate
and and ease these flows for users so
that they don't have to enter this
information manually but keep in mind if
you saw the talk that was just happening
before this on protecting users from
deception that there is in fact another
problem here which is phishing so even
with the use of one-time codes over SMS
we find that it's very common that when
a user encounters a malicious site
that's asking them for this information
they will happily enter that into this
malicious phishing website or or app so
to combat that we've been working with
the Fido Alliance to introduce api's on
Android that provide resistance to
phishing and so these are api's that
allow you as a developer to talk to the
authentication hardware built-in on
Android so things like biometric sensors
or external security keys and use that
information to help mitigate against the
phishing problem now there's a couple of
different flows that this supports so
for example imagine you have a user
coming to your app logging in for the
first time and then enrolling a
fingerprint you can really easily check
that it's that person when they come
back using this flow known as local user
verification furthermore you can support
this cross device usage where someone
comes back
another device and having enrolled a
security key or some sort of external
Authenticator previously check that it's
them on this new one so there's a couple
different flows that you can support
here and there's a few things that you
really should keep in mind so the first
is about biometrics the biometrics on
Android never leave the device so what
happens is when someone enrolls their
fingerprint they're just locally setting
up the information such that secure keys
can be released to the app or a
signature produced from them that you
could then send to your server the
biometrics themselves don't actually
leave the device and the second is that
this phishing resistance is provided by
a couple of different properties one is
that the Authenticator in question here
is either built into the device
or physically nearby and the fact then
that this credential these keys that I
mentioned which are unlocked are only
provided to your app signed with your
developer signing keys or to an
Associated website and so one thing that
you can do today when you get home is
check that the association has been set
up between your app and your website as
Carlos mentioned earlier that enables
password sharing between a native app
and a website and it will also support
this a phishing resistant login flows
with phyto credentials so that's the
tricks that you can employ in your app
to you get people signed in more
securely and I'm gonna hand it back to
Hideaki to wrap up and give you some
links for all the information we've
shown today all right so to wrap up we
want to make sure we minimize friction
for users at each step of the customer
journey so step one we want to offer
seamless signup and sign-in by using
Google sign-in smart lock for passwords
or autofill hints for credentials we
also want to automate the OTP
verification process by utilizing the
SMS retriever API next we want to
simplify the checkout process for our
users by utilizing the google pay API or
autofill hints for payment information
we also want to streamline the OTP
verification process from financial
institutions by utilizing the
the mass User Content API and finally we
want to make sure we consider security
at each step
by utilizing again Google sign-in our
safety net api's multi-factor
authentication and/or our Fido api's and
if you want more information you can
always refer to our developer pages you
can also visit our sandbox session
tomorrow afternoon from 12:30 to 4:30
p.m. in the Android platform area and
I'm gonna pause for a sec so you guys
can take notes take photos all right and
thank you very much
you